hopefully your your daughters would
enjoy it because I hear word reached me
that they're a bit Oh laughed out frozen
is no longer cutting it for them
my girls really wish that Moana was
their father their sort of over Olaf at
this point and I have to remind them
that Olaf pays for their school and a
lot pays for their the roof over their
head and those quesadillas they love
eating every Thursday so so the Olaf
isn't going anywhere anytime soon as
long as they want to keep eating and
drinking and but apparently they might
be over Olaf you or not is this the
office that has something very special
in it depends on what your definition of
specialist but it has this life like I
wasn't ready to be that big it's so
unnecessarily vagrant think about it is
the date arrived to my house it came in
a crate that was straight out of Raiders
of the Lost Ark and my wife was
literally she was ready to divorce me
because she had no idea why the hell I
would be receiving something this large
without running it by her first and
she's like it either goes in your office
or we throw it out so I got like three
grown men to help me bring it into my
office in here it sits or stands but
also because you're Josh GAD you could
never throw it out no I can never be
seen on the side of the road no no no
garbage no I could I could never
personally throw it out and and by the
way like why would like what would cause
me to throw that guy could you imagine
just walking with this thing to a large
garbage can and being like all right let
me throw out this leftover sushi and a
giant dancing hola
[Music]
you